ihr Vater ist ein Nazi doch er magt mich
ich fühle mich damit etwas unbehaglich
wie ich zu dieser Ehre komme es fraglich
ihr Vater ist ein Nazi doch er mag mich
was habe ich denn groß gemacht hab der
Mutter ein paar Blumen mitgebracht mich
vorgestellt mich zu ihm gesellt und ich
habe ihn gefragt ob es ihn was ausmacht
wenn ich seine Tochter ehrliche er sagt
sie wäre ja so eine ordentliche das
Spiele für ihn eine
wesentliche Rolle auch im Hinblick auf
die Küche und er musterte mich vom
Scheitel bis zur Sole und er fragte mich
bist du Türke oder Pole und ich sagte
nee ich bin mehr so von hier dann wollte
er noch wissen ob ich mich politisch
engagiere und ich sagte na ja kann man
so nicht sagen und er klopfte mir auf
die Schulter und sagte wir werden uns
schon vertragen und dann zeigt er mir
stolz seine Waffen Sammlung und ich
sagte alle Achtung ihr Vater ist ein
Nazi doch er mag mich ich fühle mich
damit etwas unbehaglich wie ich zu
dieser Ehre komme es fraglich ihr Vater
ist ein Nazi doch er mag mich im Sommer
war Schützenfest na klar war ich
eingeladen wie konnte ich nein sagen
wenn die da Wein haben und man kann da
am Knochen vom Schwein nagen auch wenn
die kulinarisches kredenzen die Freude
hält sich her so in Grenzen eine
Versammlung mir suspek der Existenzen
mit Uniform und volkstümlichen Tänzen
man ballert in der Gegend rum und es
wurde steif marschiert zu meinem
Entsetzen wurde ich von seinen Freunden
akzeptiert die wurden nicht müde mir zu
erzählen dass früher alles besser war
vor der Wende vor den Hippies und vor 45
sogar und sie schweren mir vom Krieg vor
darum hatte ich gar nicht gebeten und
ich wurde energisch dazuedrängt im
Schützenverein beizutreten und ich
guckte nur betreten wussteen nicht was
ich sagen soll er heftete mir schon mal
ein Orden
an toll ihr Vater ist ein Nazi doch er
mag mich ich fühle mich damit etwas
unbehaglich wie ich zu dieser Ehre komme
ist fraglich ihr Vater ist ein Nazi doch
er magt mich ihr Vater ist ein Nazi doch
er magt mich und sie sagt läuft doch
alles gut verzag nicht ich w schon wie
er mein kleines Rückgrad bricht ihr
Vater ist ein Nazi doch er magt mich jo
yeah
danke
schön scheie Objektive falsch